the next guy has over a hundred friends
on Facebook it's a big deal everybody
please never gonna do it up for Hans kid
everybody hey thank you guys it's good
to be here my name is Hans Kim and I
have a lot of confidence right now Spira
expect me so much I think confidence is
important you know it's like it's like
an ancient instinct that's very rarely
wrong you know I think without
confidence stupid people would have no
idea to pay attention to so it's useful
yeah the super people would be like
where will I go what do I talk to why my
dear okay that guy's making strong
noises that's okay and those are called
elections the system is broken man I'm
not a big fan of alpha males because
they're never about the duties and
responsibilities of being an alpha male
you know they just want to interrupt you
and brag about sex that's not an alpha
male it's a SoundCloud rapper if you
want to be an alpha male why don't you
dig an irrigation ditch so we can water
our crops or divvy up these coconuts
yeah kill babies out of yours so do some
alpha male [ __ ] you know don't just make
me feel bad I was that being an alpha
male I do not choose you to leave me I
am dating right now I'm dating a woman
who is really into yoga and choke sex
like do you enjoy breathing or not make
up your mind it's hard it's hard to date
a start date as an Asian man every what
these Asian women are beautiful not
everyone things Asian men are beautiful
which doesn't make any sense because how
do you think Asian women are created me
[ __ ] I'm a crucial part of the sexy
process
please stop trying to skip me if you
have sex with me our children will be
very beautiful half of it dull enough
will be great engineers in that support
to love the old dating game you know I
don't think I could ever have sex with a
dude sorry fellas
I've never looked at a beautiful woman
had been like wow she is gorgeous but is
there a version of her that's bigger and
hairier and his less kindness I will I
just took that in my butthole never
happened straightest [ __ ] please believe
me my dad doesn't I was talking to this
dude who's like we're so lucky we're not
gay can you imagine if most of the
gender we were attracted to wasn't
attracted to his back and I was like
whoa can't even imagine what would it be
like to be the other people
I don't understand homophobia especially
like people who use the Bible they're
like it's Adam and Eve not Adam and
Steve but I didn't Eve we're not even a
good couple bit book week okay first of
all they disobeyed God and ate of fruit
they went fuzzy which is Hannah day and
then they raised Cain and Abel and Cain
murdered Abel what are we taking packing
advice from a parent who raised to
murder a murder one murderer okay
there were only three other people on
earth he killed a quarter of the world's
population okay we play video games or
just shitty parents your start up your
[ __ ] together love I love being age and
I grew up Christian as an Asian person
which is kind of weird because the
people who wrote the Bible didn't even
seem to know that Asia is existed maybe
even drop us a line in there but an
agent's great job on inventing the
fireworks really proud of you to the
Jews
the whole things about juice I am NOT a
racist I don't even see race I only
smell it a little Lithuanian in here to
catch my drift with weightings I was
actually on an airplane and I had a
moment of racism I'm not proud to admit
but I saw a dude reading a book in
Arabic and it kind of freaked me out
but then I saw him pull the corner of
the page and put the book away and I was
like oh my God he's got future plans for
another racist
saved by the power of literature of the
Black Panther movie I thought that was a
great movie because it gave black
children a hero they could look up to
finally you know not just someone like
Martin Luther King jr. or Denzel
Washington or tuba or jay-z or Nelson
Mandela or Harriet Tubman or Maya
Angelou or Oprah now they have a fake
person that dresses like a cat
hello Caviar's schoolgirl I'm just
jealous when are they gonna come out
with a yellow panda huh where's our
movie
don't say Kung Fu Panda that's Jack
Black and the Panda is fat cartoon so
alright I'm Asian and we get made fun of
a lot because people say we eat dogs
which I understand can be very shocking
to Americans because an American doctor
treated like family members but we have
this weird little tradition in Asia
where we treat our family members like
family members
like in Asia instead of buying an animal
we love our grandma unless she's a baby
girl in case you throw in the river good
grow Christian as an Asian person but
I'm an atheist now because I'm not in
kindergarten and I have an internet
connection I think it'd be stressful to
ideology that can be destroyed by facts
walking down the street oh wow so [ __ ]
guess I could have been blowing dudes
this whole time we're up Tuesday all
right thank you guys very much
[Applause]